what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios has
finally talked about Jonathan majors and
his character Victor timely slash he who
remains slash Kang the Conqueror
Jonathan Majors the actor who plays King
the Conqueror from Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania he who remains from Loki
season 1 and upcoming new variant of
King the Conqueror Victor timely and
Loki season 2 was unfortunately arrested
several months ago on some counts of
assault his trial has not yet concluded
but ever since he was arrested his
lawyer came out his legal team came out
said that he was innocent and was
actually the victim in the situation
however and this is incredibly
unfortunate if he does wind up being
innocent he started to lose many jobs
his management team dropped him his PR
team dropped him he lost some roles for
characters he was going to play in
certain movies but we never heard
anything from Marvel Studios they never
made a statement about Jonathan Majors
but what they did do is kind kind of
stopped talking about Kang this was
during the time where Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania was coming out on
Disney plus if you looked in the
description it really didn't mention
Kang at all it gave Jonathan Majors
Credit in the casting list because of
course they have to but in the
description they simply mentioned a
villain or a threat they didn't mention
Jonathan Majors by name they didn't
mention Kang by name they kept him out
of it and they also put off releasing
the assembled piece the making of
special that Disney usually releases on
Disney plus that would simply show the
making of Ant-Man and the WASP Punta
Mania They delayed that they didn't put
that out for a very long time they
delayed it indefinitely however a lot of
evidence was presented by Jonathan
majors and his team and ultimately they
ended up releasing the assembled piece
and now Loki season 2 is right around
the corner and Marvel Studios is showing
Victor timely who of course is played by
Jonathan Majors they show him in the
trailer they show him a lot actually now
he hasn't been in any of the promos for
the show we've you've only really seen
Tom Hiddleston and Sophia dimartino we
don't have the villain he's been kept
out of the promotions for the show but
finally like I said Marvel is actually
really talking about his character and
they've done that on a pretty decent
scale they've done it in an interview
with Entertainment Weekly and in this
interview they also give us a little bit
of information about his character
Victor timely and some other characters
as well such as OB played by kihoi Kwan
in this ew article they spoke to Marvel
Studios executive producer Kevin Wright
who talked about him in the interview
and it started off by saying this season
2 will also find Loki Sylvie and Mobius
coming up against a new but familiar
Nemesis Victor timely played by Jonathan
Majors a brilliant industrialist and
inventor living in the early 1900s like
the menacing he who remains who debuted
in the first season finale timely is a
variant of Kang the Conqueror a
dimension hopping villain who takes many
forms then Entertainment Weekly goes on
to say major version of timely will play
a major role in Loki season 2 even as
the actor faces off-screen legal
troubles and then Kevin Wright said this
Victor timely is somebody that we are
very very excited about when you look at
Kang he has a very funny comic backstory
he has all these iterations timely was
one that we've always wanted to do in
Loki and I think we're really excited
about how that integrates into the
season it's a big part of the show so
this is a Marvel Studios executive
producer right here an executive
producer for Loki stating how big of a
part Jonathan Majors as Victor timely is
going to play in Loki season two this is
the most we have ever heard really from
Marvel Studios about Victor timely and
this is the first time anyone from
Marvel Studios has mentioned Jonathan
Majors which is a good sign they were
completely silent before they simply
remain neutral which is a great stance
by them but they didn't say anything
good and they didn't say anything bad
they remained completely quiet and that
was a good stance to take because Majors
was claiming he was innocent and was
actually the victim of the situation and
nothing had been brought to light yet a
lot of companies fired Majors before any
of the evidence that favored him came
out and if you haven't been following it
does seem like Jonathan majors has some
pretty great evidence that is in his
favor that could prove that he is indeed
innocent so this is a great sign coming
directly from Marvel Studios that they
do indeed plan on keeping Jonathan
majors of course it's still going to
ultimately be decided by the trial
because Marvel Studios will most likely
replace him as king the Conqueror if he
is indeed found guilty during the trial
but for now it's really really great
news because it actually sounds like
they are putting quite a bit of faith in
Jonathan majors's characters and
speaking of characters we do have new
characters in Loki season 2 and if you
are one of those people who loved the
tone of Loki season 1 and you love the
weirdness about it then we have good
news for you the article Ends by stating
above all Wright promises that Loki's
second season will continue to embrace
the weirdness of the first and then they
quote Kevin Wright and he said we made a
weird show in season one and people
responded to how weird it was so we
wanted to push it further there's a lot
more that this article reveals but first
big thank you to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video many of you may
know that I personally use hellofresh
and I love it it makes cooking fun easy
and it's affordable and that's why it's
America's number one meal kit delivered
straight to your door and you might not
know that they actually have seasonal
recipes right now since it's summer they
have their new fresh and fit summer menu
so if you're trying to get that beach
bud but you're also trying to eat really
great tasting food it's perfect for you
right now it's peak time for summer
produce and hellofresh make sure you get
all the best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days for Quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now you can go to
hellofresh.com 50 Cosmic and use code 50
Cosmic for 50 off plus 15 off the next
two months that's hellofresh.com 50
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50 off
plus 15 off the next two months
the article continues stating season 2
premiering on October 6th however we
know that that is now October 5th on
Disney plus finds Loki and Mobius
trekking into the deepest bowels of the
TBA seeking help from Quan's quirky
repair guy OB OB works and the repairs
and advanced apartment and his office is
stuffed in the basement a sprawling
mismatch of gadgets and gizmos and
here's what executive producer Kevin
Wright tells ew about what he does he
says his job speaking about OB is
basically every piece of tech every
computer everything that is running at
the TVA he either designed it or he
fixes it and keeps it running now this
lines up perfectly with what we've heard
from some insiders what we have heard is
that OB actually helped he who remains
or whatever variant of kangy was at the
time create the TVA and in some of the
trailers and the TV spots for Loki
season 2 we can actually see kihoi
Kwan's character interacting with the
Victor timely variant and you might have
heard me say this before but I don't
think this is back in time I think this
is present time TVA I do think Loki and
Mobius end up talking to Victor timely
and convince him to go to the TVA which
he probably hasn't invented yet as that
variant so Victor timely is going to be
looking at the time Loom what has been
designed by OB and he who remains and it
looks like they could be seeking the
help of this variant Victor timely to
actually help them with the time loom in
the sacred timeline and the Multiverse
in general which is another great sign
for Jonathan Majors he's going to be
very involved and again executive
producer Kevin Wright said that he's
going to play a huge role in this show
he's going to be very important so it
looks like now we can probably pretty
confidently say that if Jonathan Majors
is proven innocent and if he is indeed
the victim in the situation that he's
been in over the past few months he's
gonna remain with Marvel Studios Marvel
Studios is going to keep them on he's
going to continue to play Kang the
Conqueror Victor timely he who remains
in any other awesome variant of King the
Conqueror that we could possibly see in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I hope
he's innocent he does seem to have a lot
of evidence pointing to that fact that
he is innocent I really hope he didn't
assault that woman and I hope he can
continue to play Kang in the MCU but let
me know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below it does seem like a
good sign but what do you think and let
me know how excited you are for Loki
season two drop your thoughts in the
comments down below and don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest MCU
news and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items winner gets pick one
item and we pick a winner at the end of
each month you can also find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign